gonna be squaring off against the
southpaw cole irvin making his 28th turn
this season kype
nicole irvin a strike thrower at times
you can be guilty of throwing a few too
many strikes maybe a little bit of an
elevation issue for kohler when last
time out against a hot blue jays team
going to try to right the ship here
against the rangers
here in game two of the three game set
first pitch of the ball game is bounced
towards short now sanders charges throws
on the run one pitch went out here in
the first now isaiah kinder philippa
we do know this when he swings
at the baseball he's going to put it in
play right about 50 percent of the time
and this one lined out to right field
that's a base hit and so isaiah aboard
and we've talked about it a lot with him
the value of that contact this season
for isaiah connor falefa highest
on the rangers
[Music]
and that's a swing gonna miss a change
up at 86 miles an hour garcia strikes
out
fluff goes and the balls hit
in the air foul territory long run for
olson and olson makes it over the
shoulder catch nicely done by the gold
glove first baseman and it is west
benjamin you can see 11 games and now
his second start of the year
anybody going after the first pitch
today harrison
lifts this one into short right field
and is retired went away let's take a
look at those numbers once again for
west benjamin owen two records 7.23 era
he has been up and down quite a few
times this year between the big leagues
and the minor leagues here's marty
overall 321 is his average 10 homer's 44
rbis
deep to left field
and that baby is gone
and starlay marte
impacts the game again his 11th of the
year and that was loud pack your bags
all aboard
next stop
pound count
climb the former
oakland a and he hits this ball on a
line out into left field and into that
corner and it's a long run out there for
canna pozo into third and they'll stop
him there on the heim double it's
feeling good go ahead and ram that
heater in there see if you can crowd mr
culverson here's the one two pitch on
the way he kicks throws swung on and
missed fastball down and away at 93 and
irvine gets the big strike out of
culberson and the rangers leave runners
at second and third one one count
benjamin sets davis leads at second
here's the pitch to pinder on the way
and chad it's a live drive base hit to
left davis the third peter's up with the
ball chris around third there'll be no
play and finder singles to left scoring
davis from second and the athletics take
a two-nothing lead big hit for pinder
last night olson was four for five four
singles and four rbis so he now has 95
runs batted in on here that's a career
high
[Music]
[Applause]
driven to right field garcia's going
back still going back he's near the wall
he turns around and that baby is gone 33
for matt olson
gives him 96 rbis
and a milestone 500 well that's the way
to do it the a's have scored in three
consecutive innings and it's
three-nothing oakland
[Music]
three-two
solar hits it sharply on the ground fair
ball that went right over the bag it
goes all the way into the corner pinder
thought the ball was foul it gets by him
rounding third is peters here's the
relay he slides he is safe dj gets his
foot in there
and the rangers are on the board it's a
3-1 ball game
now pozo can add another run here with a
base hit so lack runs well out there at
second
and this one is a base hit into center
field and they're going to wave
solace to the plate here comes the throw
it's cut off
and solak is in there rbi single by pozo
it's a one-run game kenneth bounced the
third his first time up
[Music]
high and deep to center rivera is back
and he leaps and that baby is gone
that's a two-run shot from our camp
his 17th home run of the year that was
long and loud
hayes third home run today
davis hits a smash to third but it's
snagged by culberson who falls over gets
up and fires across in time to retire
davis how about that play by charlie
culberson that's a really nice play by
charlie wow
center field
tavares squares up
pinder's tagging and pinder he stopped
and he was gonna go back and then he saw
the throws going to third so he kept
coming in and he scores a sack fly for
harris at his 49th rbi and now it is 6-2
open one ball two strikes and the lefty
fires and it swung on and missed what a
day for cole irvine seven strikeouts for
cole irvine he's been very good today
seven innings allowing just a couple of
runs and it brings up peters who's one
for three with a single
2-2
peters
gets into this one a little bit that's
carrying pretty well out to left it's
gone
a two-run homer for dj peters
and this is now a two-run game
he jumped on a hanging slider there
it's his tenth home run in only 35
ranger games pozo's had two hits today
one strike pitch oh and he hits his ball
pretty well out to left field that one
gets down that's a base hit and then
it's knocked down by canna
low he'll score easily puzzle with the
rbi double he's made it a one run game
and now
he's the tying run in scoring position
jonah heim the batter with the tying run
at second in a six-five game here in the
eighth inning oh two to jonah heim
and he hits his ball pretty well
deep out to left field it is gone
a monster two-run homer for jonah heim
puts the rangers in front 7-6 an rbi's
25 and 26. wow the top of the orders
tavares goes after the first pitch well
he puts a pretty good charge into this
one and that one carrying pretty well it
is gone
a home run for leote tavares
as the rangers grabs from insurance with
a lead off homer
and it's now eight to six texas tavares
was ready
he knew
brown line drive face it right center
field
brown makes a big turn he needs to stay
close to first base no reason for him to
try to get to second and the ball game
stays alive for harrison
barlow set and the pitch to harrison
high fly ball to center here comes
adoles and a diving catch in right field
by garcia and that's how this one ends
that is a
very disappointing loss for the
athletics